if you are hungry AF during your period
while dealing with debilitating bloating
cravings and other not so sexy symptoms
I promise you you're not alone I'm a
dietitian let's talk about your diet at
different parts of your cycle and how
you can make Shark Week suck a little
less hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome
to Abby's kitchen
[Music]
foreign
snacks while talking all about wanting
to eat all the things when you get that
visit from and flow a big thank you to
my dietitian colleague Erin Davis for
supporting on the research on this video
Aaron is an amazing dietitian offering
one-on-one support from a weight neutral
lens so I will leave her information
below to reach out also a quick note
that sometimes I will use the word women
to refer to folks who menstruate but of
course I acknowledge that this is not
necessarily representative of all cases
also if you haven't subscribed get on it
and to download my free Hunger cushion
combo ebook for some healthy balanced
meal and snack ideas let me hop in here
super quick to tell you about my sponsor
toon blast so I've always been a
multitasker and as I've gotten older
I've kind of realized that passively
watching a show so this doesn't do it
for me the same way that the active Act
of playing something does and I heard
about toon blast through a gamer on my
team and I've been pretty addicted since
if you like puzzle games and cute
animals you will love this game
basically you blast cubes to create
combos that take you to the next level
which then helps all the cute characters
like Bruno bear travel around to
different magical worlds there are over
7 000 fun levels and you can join a team
to work with other players and unlock
awesome rewards the more active your
team is the more lives and coins you get
to earn this is actually a free to play
mobile game available on all devices and
you don't even need Wi-Fi to play so
this is a really really great game for
when you're traveling and you don't want
to use up all your data so if you want
to try out a game with millions of
reviews and high ratings on the App
Store and Google Play you can download
toon blast using the link in my
description or you can scan the QR code
on screen so use my link in the top line
of the description for three hours of
unlimited life and a hundred free coins
happy playing
so first things first there is no
question that reproductive female
hormones can have an impact on our
appetite and our gut depending on where
you are in your cycle we'll see changes
in our appetite regulator ppy the rate
of our gastric emptying and also how
many calories we actually burn and
therefore need so let's talk about all
these little quirks of Shark Week first
up hunger and Cravings the number one
concern that I hear from all of you when
it comes to your period is that you want
to eat all the things and typically not
always the healthiest things so this
typically starts to rev up somewhere
between ovulation and your period AKA
when you're PMSing and in some cases
into the early days of Code Red
this is because progesterone tends to
Peak right before a period and anyone
who's ever taken progesterone birth
control pills or has had to take
injections for fertility treatments
knows that progesterone makes you hungry
as and there's a few reasons why
this is so one it stimulates our hunger
hormone ghrelin which can make us want
to eat more and two progesterone can
slightly increase blood glucose and
reduce insulin sensitivity which can
also make us more likely to Crave Foods
particularly more carbs interestingly
most people tell me that they have the
munchies during their actual period when
they're bleeding when the progesterone
levels are actually going back down so
the reason for food cravings
particularly carbs when our monthly
visitor is in town is actually more
related to cortisol serotonin and
estrogen so our stress hormone cortisol
tends to be higher during these early
days of our period in the follicular
phase which can in turn increase food
Cravings meanwhile during the PMs and
period phases our estrogen levels are at
an all-time low and estrogen can also
cause our serotonin levels to drop most
of us intuitively know that carbs boost
our feel-good hormone serotonin so we
are just more likely to naturally seek
out more of those yummy tasting Foods
especially carbs when we're surfing the
Crimson wave so I'm personally we can't
change our hormones unless you want to
get pregnant or you want to take
endogenous hormones obviously but if
period cravings and hunger are getting
you down here are some of my expert tips
first of all don't make a big deal with
this folks it's actually worth pointing
out that your metabolism is actually a
bit higher during the luteal AKA PMS
phase so you could actually be needing
as much as 200 and 300 calories more and
even if you didn't I say just exercise
some compassion here and listen to what
your body needs even if that need is
more emotion based it is okay to eat
more carbs like you're crampy you're
Moody like let yourself have some Lucky
Charms to get you through another day
but to stabilize your blood sugars and
energy levels and therefore your mood
you want to focus on dressing up those
naked carbs with Hunger crushing
compounds so if you want pancakes serve
it with some Greek yogurt berries and
little drizzle of peanut butter if you
want pasta throw in some protein and
serve it with a fresh green salad add
don't take things away and the kids are
gonna be all right
next let's talk about bloating and
constipation but first I gotta wash my
hands because it looked like I just got
into my diva cup so there are a number
of reasons why we bloat during different
phases of our cycle so during your
actual period week the rise in
prostaglandins can increase our uterine
contractions which can cause painful
cramping and also bloating but a lot of
the bloat and constipation actually
occurs right before we get our monthly
visitor in those kind of not so pleasant
PMS days so as discussed progesterone is
highest during the PMS phase and one of
progesterone's not so sexy side effects
is to slow Transit Time Down AKA back
you the up
so if you find yourself thrown off your
usual bathroom routine and feeling
really bloated as a result progesterone
is probably the reason why so what can
you do if you're struggling with
pre-period bloating and constipation
three main things come to mind here
fiber water and movement so you want to
focus on getting at least 25 grams of
fiber per day which is going to help to
bulk up your stool and make it more
easily travel through the GI tract so
whole grains fruits veggies nuts legumes
are all great sources two if you are up
in your fiber you need to get in more
water to complement it fiber that water
is just typically going to make things a
lot worse and three you want to move
your body and I know that this might
seem like a slog when you're in a pissy
mood and you just want to sit on the
couch and watch rom-coms balls deep in B
and J key word here is and
but getting in at least a little daily
walk here not only can really help to
boost mood when it's down but it also
helps to move stool through the bowels
to promote regularity other specific
foods that can give you a little bit of
an extra poop boost are things like
kiwis prunes Ginger flax Chia and fiber
supplements like psyllium or partially
hydrolyzed guar gum finally let's talk
about period poops but first I gotta pop
this into the freezer and I'll meet you
back here for step two a little longer
than a few minutes later how simple
would life be if we could just have a
regular consistent bowel movement every
week of the month like the other 50 of
the population but no we got a seesaw
from being backed up and Bloated to
nearly shooting ourselves multiple times
a day so to what do we owe this pleasure
well when we're on our period especially
in those first few days of the
follicular stage those prostaglandins
that we talked about earlier that cause
cramps can also do a number on our
bowels since our intestines are so close
to our uterus it can stimulate bowel
contractions and cause urgency and loose
stools we also know that the brain and
the gut are so intimately intertwined
not to mention our stress hormone as we
discussed is Raging and our general
emotional state is a bit out of whack
when we're on our rag so again not
surprisingly Risa suggests that women
who experience and emotional symptoms
are more likely to also report GI
symptoms hold that thought I'm gonna
melt this chocolate
one minute 37 seconds later I mean
I probably could have just skipped the
whole video and just told you to do this
but where was I
poop
what do you do if you got the period
poops I feel like that should be a song
poops the period poops the period poops
no but seriously number one hydrate if
you are having loose stools it is super
important to go easy on the caffeine
which can further stimulate the bowels
and instead you want to focus on
rehydration so this means lots of water
and potentially considering an
electrolyte supplement if you're feeling
extra depleted food wise you want to
focus on small meals every few hours
that are typically lower in fat and
lower in fiber really binding foods like
rice unripe bananas soda crackers toast
that kind of stuff I'm probably going to
use a lot of chocolate on just one of
these but do you think I care absolutely
not I think this is the way to do it
folks so to recap every month is its own
literal roller coaster I'm not saying
that it's ever going to feel fair but we
can try to make these symptoms suck a
little bit less by knowing our monthly
patterns and their side effects and
adjusting our diet and lifestyle to feel
our best and another reminder to
download toon blast if you're looking
for a fun new game to play by using the
link in the description happy playing so
I really hope that this was helpful for
any of you guys who are struggling
during that time of the month if you
like this video be sure to give it the
thumbs up or a yogurt pop-up leave me a
comment below and I'll see you next time
on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]